okay so we are doing Facebook mentions
while we're recording this video for the
folks on YouTube who are part of the top
entrepreneur book club online it's
exciting to have as many subscribers
that we have around the world and
winners around the world will announce
people right now who have a reviewed the
top three best reviews for the book and
it's very basic again quick reminder how
to be part of this book club every
single month I choose a book for us to
read as entrepreneurs around the world
when we choose the book as we read
there's three things to do to
participate in the book club number one
is post shared the post on your platform
so share the posts with following their
you have if you do that every single
month we pull a raffle out and you win a
$50 gift card one person wants a $50
gift card to Amazon second thing is the
link that I have in the description here
for Facebook mentions you don't see
there right now but we'll put it on
YouTube as well on the bottom in the
description side go to the link with the
book-of-the-month and in the link on my
website Patrick Bay david.com tack three
people tack three people to invite them
to the book club our goal is to have 10
million readers with us around the world
joining this book club and so to do that
we want to invite as many people as
possible tack 3 people to be part of
this
anybody that tags three people you go on
a separate raffle we pull your name you
win $100 gift card to Amazon and for the
month of March you're right top three
reviews the top two the reviews
everybody writes to review some
different platforms the top three
reviews that you write on Patrick Bay
David come on the link of the book of
the month we pulled the three names and
in first place gets the top prize second
place in third place for instance for
the month of March Book of the Month was
17 indisputable laws of teamwork by John
Maxwell and the top three prizes number
three was a hundred dollar gift card to
Starbucks number two was a Mike it was a
podcast Mike for number two which is
really cool and a number one is a six
inch HD screen Kendall for first place
winner that will have so with that being
said let me go out go out there and
recognize the winners Mario let's first
do two shares
let's first do the shares this is for
who has who wins a $50 gift card
we'll do a raffle your who wins a $50
gift card for for sharing the post with
other people and the winner is let me
pull up this $50 gift card winner that
we have trying to hold this thing in the
head at the same time okay so the $50
gift card to Amazon for sharing the post
goes to Jonathan Pina Pina Pina Jonathan
P Nia you win a $50 gift card to Amazon
if you know Jonathan Pina private
message more you grab this named
Jonathan penny as the winner private
messages will connect with you Mario
will connect with you and send you the
$50 gift card congratulations thanks for
sharing a post with other people now
it's about the hundred dollar gift card
that we have the $100 gift card that we
have for people who tagged three
different people for people who tagged
three different people to invite them to
the book club
this is a hundred dollar gift card to
Amazon this goes to Martin Jones jr.
Martin Jones jr. congratulations private
messages if you know Martin Jones make
sure you let him know to private
messages congratulations you $100 gift
card now let's talk about the top three
best reviews it was a lot to choose from
but will tell you about the top three
best reviews the first one the
third-place one that one's a hundred
dollar gift card to Amazon I really like
this one here's why I liked it this is
how she opens it up before she rises to
reveal I highly recommend you reading
the review on what she picked up from
the law of the niche that was her
favorite law of the book she said first
of all may I start may I say that I did
not read a single book last year this
year I have already read five in the
past month and it's absolutely amazing
the winner of the third place best
review is ray naughty ray naughty rei
nati ray naughty congratulations to you
you win a $100 gift card to Starbucks
what I'm excited for you is yet you have
you have entered a world of reading
books and what that's going to do to
your mind and the way you're going to
start thinking and processing things and
what that's going to do to your life is
as exciting you'll notice the difference
immediately but congratulations you $100
gift card to Starbucks second place
best review was from Hawaii our buddy
Nico Vargas great review I like how you
explained and you kind of responded to
the challenge I give you last month you
you did and I don't think you want to
top the review but you did write a great
review this time you want second place
for the review which means you win the
podcast Mike private messages we'll send
that over to you I like how you're
implementing things that are helping you
out with this book more you got a
question on the side so the way you
become part of the book club is you need
to go to Patrick baby be calm when you
go to Patrick Brady be calm Ilia link
Patrick Wayne even calm Mario let's put
an annotation on the YouTube side go to
Patrick video be calm click on the book
club all the way at the top on the
website then go subscribe to the
newsletter you'll automatically
participate in the emails that will be
sending for those that are part of the
book club so if you click on the link
that's in dimensions here you'll go to
the site immediately good question ok
first place best review you want a brand
spanking new HD Kendall six inch sent
over to you and this goes to Kristin
pizza luke rent Patel petal Kiran petal
Curran don't know how to pronounce it
great first name would ek Kristin petal
Corrine and she talks about how one
thank you for all the free knowledge you
get I want your value taming channel
since 2015 since then I keep watching
videos because I feel like it's
personally mentor me I really like your
book club I repented so many other
people read two to four books a month
since two thousand forty nights them I
love it so she's become an absolute book
fanatic reading fanatic and in there she
explains every single law and what she
picked up them from the law I'm not
gonna go through though right now but I
highly recommend if you haven't read the
book go read her review on patrick beta
be calm she wrote a fantastic review on
the youtube video here
Ilia why don't we put the screen her
review what it looks like we'll put a
screenshot here congratulations you in
the first place
kendall private messages mario will send
a gift over to you Marv you got a
question on this side a great question
what I'm looking for in a summary would
book review is not necessarily what's in
it it's what you
do to apply it in your own life I like
hearing stories of people that read a
book and I apply this in this part of my
life and it helped me get these results
that's what I want to know about this
part of the book helped me do X Y Z as
well as in three paragraphs the most I'm
not looking for the longest necessarily
three paragraphs the most but I want it
to be substance not copy/paste from a
blog somebody else wrote it's pretty
easy to search for that something that
you really put from your own personal
life okay so now let's talk about the
book of the month for the month of April
it was book of the month it's a book
I've really loved I loved the author I
think Patrick Lencioni is a phenomenal
author he's written many great books
five dysfunctions of a team being one of
his best ones but this one book he wrote
you ought to be able to read this book
in one sitting and post a review on the
website right off the back because it's
very easy to read this book
but there is so much content in it and
it's called five temptations of a CEO
five temptations of a CEO Ilia on this
side let's put the image of what the
book looks like five temptations of a
CEO by Patrick Lencioni I'm excited
about reading that book because he gets
so direct and honest about the mistakes
CEOs make to try to please everybody or
try to it's a very very fantastic book
for all entrepreneurs to read from the
lowest level entrepreneur to the highest
level somebody that's running a company
doing a high revenue high volume revenue
there's a lot of value to be learned
from this book and it's a simple read
and the prices are gonna be different
you're gonna love the prices for the
month of April what the winners are
gonna be getting third place will be
$100 gift cards to iTunes download any
kind of audible you want to do any kind
of music you want to listen to iTunes
hundred dollar gift card number two is
what I'm excited about and I'll tell
your Mario pick number one number two is
custom Nike ID Jordans to make you tell
us what you want it to look like will
customize it whatever type of color you
want put it together will place the
order it'll be sent over to you have one
myself and I love how it looks you can
add your own color twist to it your
company your brand your team name
whatever it is it's really fascinating
how to do it on this side
Ilia again put the picture on there he
cannot do it on
first place you know what first place is
gonna be this time best review first
place first place this time for a book
of demands five dysfunctions of a No
five temptations of a seal first place
you know what first places let me tell
you what first places oh yeah you can
give us a drumroll can you for three
seconds first place will get a brand
spankin new Apple watch is what's gonna
be given to the top review given to the
person with the top review on five
temptations of a CEO you will get that
so with that being said click on the
link that's in the description on this
side go to the site or did a book read
the book tak three people on the post on
the bottom of my website share the post
on your social media platform on
Facebook once you do that you'll
participate in next month's shares will
get $50 if we pull your name tag three
people will participate in 100 bucks
and in top three reviews by May 1st you
can write it sooner many people write a
lot sooner than then will participate in
the top three prizes $100 itunes custom
Nike idea Jordan shoes number one Apple
watch so go out there and click on the
link go subscribe to the book club
buy the book tag three people and cannot
wait to see your reviews on May 1st or
sooner
thank you everybody bye-bye
you